Paschian.
Ist schön.
Hallo.
Guten Tag.
Ja, hallo.
Usta, Usta ist mein Name und ich bin zuständig als für Sie heute.
Okay.
Ich würde mit Ihnen eine Musiksprachkontrolle führen.
Aber bevor wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden sprechen, würde ich auch
eine persönliche Frage stellen.
Okay.
Sind Sie dabei für Stammren?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Johannes Schwarz.
Johannes und Schwarz.
Johannes mit Haar und zwei End.
Johannes Schwarz.
Schwarz wie weiß und schwarz.
Ja, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 34 Jahre alt.
34 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß und 77 kg schwer.
1,78 m groß.
Ja.
Und 77 kg schwer.
77 kg.
Und wann sind Sie gerne geboren?
Ich bin am 3.3.1989 geboren.
1989.
Okay.
Und sehr schön.
Und was führt Sie zu uns?
Unsere Folgendes.
Vor ungefähr einer Woche habe ich Rückenschmerzen bekommen im Bereich meiner Ländwirbelsäule.
Die sind seit zwei Tagen schlimmer geworden.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie mir helfen können.
Was habe ich denn?
Sie haben vor einer Woche gesagt, Rückenschmerzen und habe Sie Rückenschmerzen, nur Rückenschmerzen.
Nein, Rückenschmerzen meine ich von den Ländern.
Die Ländwirbelsäule.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von einem bis zehn?
Wobei ein sehr leichter Schmerz von zehn ausordernen starker Schmerzen entspricht?
Ich würde sagen acht.
Okay.
Ich zahle die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion aus.
Ja, in meinem linken Bein.
Nur linken Bein.
Nur linken Bein oder rechten.
Ne, nur links.
Nur linken Bein.
Und auch andere in einer anderen Körperregion?
Nein, in einer anderen Körperregion nicht.
Ich habe nur Rückenschmerzen, die in meinem linken Bein ausstrahlen.
Haben Sie die Schmerzen immer verschlechtert?
Nicht immer, sondern seit zwei Tagen.
Das hat sich verschlechtert.
Also seit einer Woche habe ich die Schmerzen und seit zwei Tagen ist es schlimmer geworden.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, da habe ich Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
600 Milligramm.
Und was noch?
Nur Ibuprofen?
Ja.
Sehr gute Auswahl, glaube ich.
Und wie haben die Schmerzen begonnen?
Ja, ich bin morgens aufgestanden.
Und wollte vom Bett aufstehen.
Vor einer Woche?
Vor einer Woche.
Und beim Aufstehenversuch habe ich einen stechenen Schmerz gehabt.
Ja.
Das war erst mal bis vor zwei Tagen ein normaler stechender Schmerz im Rücken.
Und seit zwei Tagen habe ich eine Verschlimmerung der Schmerzen
mit einer Schmerzaustrahlung in den linken Beinen.
Sind Sie deswegen bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Oder zum ersten Mal?
Nein, ich bin jetzt hier bei Ihnen.
Okay.
Und gibt es einen Auslöser, würde ich merken?
Bestimmt Auslöser.
Auslöser?
Ja, ich hatte einen Tag davor bei meinem Freund beim Umzug geholfen.
Vielleicht deswegen.
Ja, umzug, ja.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen, Lindach oder Verstärken?
Nein, Verstärken ist, wenn ich sitze und aufstehen möchte,
habe ich verstärkte Schmerzen.
Und Körperänderung?
Verstärkte Schmerzen?
Genau, bei einer körperlichen Bewegung, verstärkte Schmerzen.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Fieber, Herr Schwarz?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Sind Ihnen, haben Sie, haben Sie das Belfin verloren?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen natrischweiß aufgefallen?
Nein.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Sehr gut.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Sport?
Ja.
Hobby-mäßig Fußball.
Fußball.
Wie oft?
Ich habe es in der Woche, in der Halle mit Freunden.
Ja, drei Mal pro Woche.
Und werden Sie Fußball spielen?
Dabei lenden tut es weh, oder?
Da habe ich diese Woche nicht gemacht, weil ich Schmerzen habe.
Ich habe da nicht gespielt.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist gut.
Und gibt es etwas?
Gibt es andere Beschiwerden, die auch Beschiwerden begleiten?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie Schmerzen bekommen,
haben Sie vielleicht Übelkrank?
Nein, ich habe keine Begleiterkrankung, wenn ich
Ja, ich würde Ihnen nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte fragen.
Aber davor möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, Gabless, in Ihrer Vorgeschichte.
Irgendwelche wichtigen Erkrankungen?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Zum Beispiel, die Bluthochturm, erhöhte Blutfettwerte,
oder Diabetes-Militus-Superkrankheit.
Nein, ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich profiliere bei Bedarf.
Was noch?
Nein, nichts.
Gabes, in Ihrer Vorgeschichte, wichtigen Operationen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wichtig ist, aber mein Blutdamm wurde entfernt,
wo ich 15 Jahre alt war.
Ist die Operation Konfliktation los?
Ja, sobald ich mich erinnern kann.
Hatten Sie Allergien, weil während der Operation, wissen Sie?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern.
Meine Eltern haben mir auch nichts gesagt.
Generell haben Sie Allergien?
Ja, ich kann Nüsse nicht essen.
Nur Nüsse?
Ja, nur Nüsse.
Wie äußert sich die Nüsseallergien?
Mit Atemnot.
Sehr schwer.
Mein Hals wird in den Drick dick.
Sehr wichtige Informationen.
Ich würde mit Ihnen über Ihre Familien vorgeschrieben sprechen.
Es gab Leiden, Ihr Vater oder Ihre Geschwister und Mutter
an wichtige Erkrankungen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wichtig ist, aber mein Vater hat
Bluthochdruckerkrankung und Herzrhythmestörung.
Meine Mutter hat eine schildrüsen Unterfunktion.
Sie ist übergewichtig und hat Druckerkrankt.
Ich glaube, der ist Typ 2.
Und Geschwister haben Sie?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Sind Sie Meinslichen?
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Nein, ich hätte gerne noch einen Bruder und eine Schwester.
Was ist Ihre Option?
Ich möchte über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten sprechen.
Möchten Sie davor etwas hinzufügen?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich hinzufügen sollte.
Sie haben mir alles gefragt.
Ich komme mit dem Bruder und frage mich 50 Sachen.
Können Sie bis Ende des Gesprächs die Schmerzen aushalten?
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange das Gespräch noch dauert.
Wenn wir bis morgen früh reden, dann kann ich das nicht aushalten.
Aber für ein paar Minuten kann ich das noch aushalten.
Entschuldigung, ich möchte bei dir entschuldigen,
dass ich die Medikamente fragen.
Rauchen Sie Herr Schmetz?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gelegentlich.
Ab und zu, wenn es ein Feier ist.
Ansonsten tricke ich nicht Alkohol.
Können wir sagen, einmal pro Woche oder einmal pro Monat?
Ich würde sagen gelegentlich.
Manchmal kann es in der Woche sein,
auch 5-mal pro Monat sein.
Je nach, wie wenn es Feier ist, Sommer, Winter weniger.
Aber nicht regelmäßig.
Nehmen Sie das nicht persönlich,
das ist eine Routinefrage, die ich jedem Patienten stellen muss.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen ein?
Ich weiß noch, ob es Drogen geschrieben wird.
Sind Sie geimpft?
Geimpft? Nein.
Ich würde Ihnen die Impfung empfehlen.
Aber das ist...
Die Kinderimpfung, die man in der Kindheit bekommen hat,
habe ich gezogen, weil meine Eltern das gemacht haben.
Okay, du hast mich geimpft.
Ab den 18.Limps habe ich mich nicht mehr impfen lassen.
Ich möchte das.
Ich vertraue an die Natur.
Sehr gut.
Ich habe alle wichtigen...
Soziale Anämnese.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Beruflich. Ich bin Student.
Student?
Langzeit Student, ja.
Sind Sie feierdaten?
Nein.
Wollen Sie allein?
Mit meiner Freundin.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Sehr gut.
Was ist das, alle meine Fragen?
Möchten Sie etwas ins Kredit?
Wie geht es denn weiter, Doktor?
Ich kläre Ihnen jetzt, was wir machen wollen.
Zuerst möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann...
Ich möchte Ihnen ein bisschen Blut ab...
Was hast du gesagt? Ich habe es nicht gehört.
Ich nehme Ihnen ein bisschen Blut ab.
Wie viel ist ein bisschen?
Ein oder zwei Typ.
Was ist ein Typ?
Das ist ein Blutstück.
Blutus, meinen Sie?
Blut?
Blutus.
Oder Blutröhrchen?
Ja, Blutröhrchen.
Und dann...
Ich möchte...
Ich möchte ländenwebelsoil...
Rundgen...
in ländenwebelsoil...
Rundgen veranlassen.
Okay.
Und ich möchte...
einen Zugang in die Wehen...
in den Wehen legen.
Okay.
Vielleicht ein Schmerzmittel geben.
Ah, okay.
Und dann...
Ich wollte gerade fragen, warum soll ich einen Zwenenzugang bekommen?
Aber wegen Schmerzmittel haben Sie gesagt.
Gut.
Schmerzinfusion anlegen.
Und dann...
Ja, und nach der Ergebnis...
nach der Ergebniskonjunktur...
wieder...
aktuelle Situation...
Ich habe es jetzt nicht verstanden.
Nach der Ergebnis...
möchte ich mit Ihnen...
nach dem alle Ergebnisse da sind...
über Ihre aktuelle Situation...
wieder besprechen.
Besprechend.
Nicht wieder besprechend.
Okay.
Aber Kollegen oder Kolleginnen, andere Fragen?
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, eine Ründgenuntersuchung.
Was ist das? Ist das gefährlich?
Nein, es ist nicht gefährlich.
Die Ründgenaufnahme ist schmerzfrei.
Schmerzfrei unter Druckung.
Aber ein bisschen...
Ründgenaufnahme hat ein bisschen Strahlen.
Strahlen, aber...
ist nicht gefährlich.
Was können Sie zu Strahlen machen?
Aber es ist...
weniger geringe Losierung.
Deswegen ist es nicht gefährlich.
Okay.
Also...
zu meinen geringen Strahlen...
Was können diese geringe Strahlen machen?
Was bedeutet geringe Strahlen?
Sie sagen, ich kann ein wenig Gift einnehmen.
Ist nicht gefährlich.
Aber das ist nicht gefährlich.
Normalerweise...
die Sonne...
die Sonne, die Strahlen...
der Sonne ist...
bekommen wir...
jeden Tag.
Und die Sonne hat eine geringe Strahlung...
wie die Ründgenaufnahme.
Okay.
Deswegen ist es nicht gefährlich.
Also ich würde sagen...
ich habe mal gehört, dass Ründgenstrahlen
ein Tumor erzeugen kann.
Erzeugen kann.
Wenn etwas kann, kann es gefährlich sein.
Aber das Risiko ist sehr, sehr, sehr gering.
Aber das Risiko ist da.
Das Risiko, das man durch Sonne strahlen...
auch eine bösartige Erkrankung bekommen kann, ist da.
Ein Hauteumor.
Aber das Risiko ist äußerst gering.
Das Risiko ist äußerst gering.
Ja, das Risiko ist äußerst gering.
Okay.
Gut, danke, Herr Doktor.
Dann gucken wir mal.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass ihr beim Muskelgewinn
ein Tauphausgefühl...
Ja, ich kann meinen Fuß nicht hochheben.
Nein, ich kann meinen Fuß nicht hochheben.
Mir ist kein Taupausgefühl.
Kein Taupazgefühl, aber habe ich auch.
Aber meinen Fuß kann ich nicht hochheben.
Okay.
Und Taupatsgefühl haben Sie gesagt, das habe ich am obersten, die Außenseite,
und dann läuft es vorne am Schienbein runter bis zu meinem Großziel.
Großziel.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben, sind die Schmerzen dumm, stechend, brennend?
Ja, ziehen.
Ziehen die Schmerzen, es zieht in meine Beine rein.
Okay.
Wie viele Milligramm?
600 Milligramm, bei Bedarf.
Manchmal eine Tablette, manchmal nicht, zwei Tabletten, auf einmal,
oder wenn es sehr schlimm ist, also bei Bedarf.
Die Schmerzen, Lindert oder Versteck, hat...
Lindert ist meine Schmerzen.
Ja, wenn ich das einnehme, Lindert ist meine Schmerzen, meine Schmerzen werden weniger.
Aber die sind dann nicht weg, sondern die werden weniger.
Kann ich das besser aushalten?
Zum Beispiel Verletzung müssen wir fragen.
Sie haben gesagt, brennend, nach der Umzug auf die Zettel sind,
aber wir müssen fragen, Verletzung.
Zum Beispiel, hatten Sie einen Umfall?
Ein Unfall, nee, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ziemvoll, umfall, umfragen gestärkt, ziemvoll, oder?
Ich stellte, das hatte ich gerne, aber egal.
Ja, man kann, hatten Sie einen Unfall, kann man fragen,
wenn ich einen Umzug mache, beim Umzug helfen,
kann ich auch einen Unfall haben, kann man fragen.
Haben Sie während des Umzuges einen Unfall gehabt?
Oder haben Sie sehr schwere Sachen gehoben?
Könnten wir Arsatzgescheppe anfangen?
Ja, wir können anfangen.
Ja, guten Abend, Kollegen.
Ja, hallo, guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen,
die ich gerade gesehen habe.
Ich möchte über die Beleitung sagen.
Bitte schön, schießen Sie mal los.
Ja, es geht um Johannets Spaß
und der 34 Jahre alt
und dritte, dritte, 1989,
jahre und ein Meter, 75,
Prost und 77, kloganschweig.
Und der Patient hat sich bei uns
wegen seit einer Woche bestehende
und seit zwei Tagen progredierte
starker Schmerzen im länden Wirbelsoil vorgestellt.
Noch mal, bitte.
Der Patient hat sich bei uns heute
wegen seit einer Woche bestehende
und seit zwei Tagen zunehmend
starker Schmerzen im länden Wirbelsoil vorgestellt.
Ja.
Die Intensität der Schmerzen
auf die Beleitung eines Kreuzstahlers
bei acht und zehn.
Bei acht und zehn.
Und der Patient hat dagegen
einen Ibografe,
sechsundart Meter, eingegangen.
Und das hat ihm geholfen.
Und im Lanfe des Seils
haben die Schmerzen
die Beleitung von Schmerzen
auf die Beleitung des Seils
und die Beleitung des Seils.
Und der
die Verneklagte,
Verneklagte, die Schmerzbeschiebungen
in der linken Band
aus.
Er fühlt
linken Bein
traurbar.
Wie würden Sie sonst beschreiben, medizinisch?
Parästhesie.
Er hat Parästhesie im linken Beinen.
Wo genau?
Wo vorne Seite hinten hat er das Beschrieb?
Außenseite.
An dem lateralen Oberschenkel.
Und wo weiter noch?
Hat er noch gesagt, wo weiter?
Hat er noch Torpatsgefühl gehabt?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das kann auch zum Großzehrausstrahlen.
Außenseiten und auch Torp sein.
Die Frage nach
Fieber, Nachweist und Schnüffel.
Im Moment, das sind ja schon mal andere Anamnäse.
Bleiben wir noch bei der speziellen Anamnäse. Hat der Patient auch Paräse?
Muskelschwäche? Paräse?
Ja.
Was für, wie äußert sich das?
Was hat er gesagt, was kann er nicht bewegen?
Wo hat er eine Kraftmuskelschwäche?
Wenn er sich bewegt,
wie
haben Schmerzen?
Nicht mehr.
Paräse. Hat er zum Beispiel
eine Fußheberparäse? Ja.
Fuß, Fuß anheben.
Fußheben. Paräse.
Paräse.
Eine Kraftlosigkeit,
um die Kraft den Fuß hochzuheben.
Okay.
Und die Frage nach Fieber,
Schnüffel, Schnüffel, Schnüffel, Schnüffel.
Nachweist wurden von den Patienten
hinein.
Bei Vorenglösen
sind keine relevanten Vorvorragungen
bei ihm.
Er hat Lust, aller Gehen.
Sie
mit dem Atem noch
sich mit dem Atem noch äußert.
Ja.
Er hat
in der Familie Aralmese
Arterie, Arterie, Hypertonie,
bei Vater
und Hypo, Hypo, Hypothryose
und Hypobesite.
Wie hat sie gesagt?
Ich habe chatt mit
Deutschland.
Das ist Deutsch, aber deutsch Medizinisch,
Absicht.
A Debositas,
Hypo, Hypothryose,
und er ist ein Einzelkind und er ist nicht raucher und er trinkt Alkohol gelegentlich.
Die Frage nach Drogenkonsum wurde bei den Patienten gemeint und sie hatte Appendie zu mir.
Appendie zu Dormie mit 15.
Er ist Student.
Er ist Student und lebt mit Freunden und hat keine Kinder.
Ich möchte den Patienten knopperlich untersuchen und aus dem Blut möchte ich Entschuldungparameter und ein kleines Blutbild.
Ich möchte ein Blut aufnahme der ja Lendenwirbel-Eule in zwei Ebenen veranlassen und gegebenenfalls ein MRT veranlassen.
Was würden Sie in einer Röntgenaufnahme sehen?
Was möchten Sie mit einer Röntgenaufnahme bezwecken oder beweisen oder ausschließen?
Die Höhe von Wirbelsäulen oder Wirbel ist gering oder normale Höhe.
Ich möchte sehen ob die Zähne oder Spinalverkürmung sponderlich ist.
Ich möchte sehen ob wirbelsäule direkt senkrecht oder nicht.
Ich möchte sehen ob eine Skoliose vorliegt oder eine normale Lodose vorliegt.
Was ist eine normalen Höhe?
Was kann eine Patologische bei einem 30-jährigen Vorstamm verursachen?
Wenn einer keinen Unfall hat und durch Umzugsarbeiten eine Faktur haben sollte,
Es kann zwei Sachen, das wirbelkörper einrichten.
Wir sagen in Deutschland Osteporose, nicht siehst.
Osteporose, okay. Genau.
Und das andere wäre?
Oder Portkrankheit.
Was? Portkrankheit.
Sobald ich wegen, wegen jetzt, Tuberkulose.
Tuberkulose, ja. Können wir auch, aber in Deutschland ist Tuberkulose nicht so verbreitet.
Ein Tumor erkrankt.
Tumor, Maliknit.
Genau, eine Maliknit.
Maliknit. Maliknit. Maliknit. Maliknit.
Maliknit. Maliknit. Maliknit.
Nicht Maliknit.
Nee, nicht Maliknit. Nein.
Maliknit. Maliknit.
Könnte da hinterstecken.
Okay.
Aber, was wir gesagt haben mit der Höhe, man kann auch den Bandscheibenfach.
Ja, Bandscheibenfach, okay.
Die Höhe der Bandscheibenfach auch verstellen.
Und dann, wenn es glatt begrenzt ist,
oder ob da eine Osterchondrose vorliegt,
auf der Bandscheibenfach verringert ist, kann man feststellen,
ob zwischen dem zwei Wirbelkörpern ein Wirbelgleiten vorhanden ist.
Was ist der ärztliche Begriff für Wirbelgleitwirbel?
Würden Sie bitte wiederholen.
Könnte zum Beispiel auch Wirbelkörper gleiten, sozusagen.
Was ist der fachliche Begriff für Gleitwirbel?
Distokation.
Nein.
Das beschreibt man nicht.
Das ist auch eine Distokation, aber das beschreibt man nicht.
Relapses.
Nein, das Relapses beschreibt die Bandscheibe.
Es geht um zwei Wirbelkörper, die dann gleiten.
Eine Spondylolisthese.
Spondylolisthese.
Kann man auch im Röntgen beurteilen.
Ja, die Umgangskneidung, die vier oder die fünf Jahre.
Herr Kollege, ich möchte Sie sagen, Herr Kollege,
die Trammer sind in einem bestimmten Teil der Trammer.
Was?
Trammer sind in einem bestimmten Teil der Trammer.
Nehmen wir mal an, Sie haben Röntgenaufnahme gemacht.
Sie haben dort eine normale Wirbelsäule.
Altersentsprechende, normale Wirbelsäule festgestellt.
Sie haben noch eine Aufnahme gesagt.
Was finden Sie sonst noch?
MRT.
MRT, Lande Wirbelsäule.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Röntgen
und einem MRT-Untersuchung?
Der Hauptunterschied.
Bei einem MRT können wir eine Weiszeit des Wirbelsäules sehen.
Darstellen.
Darstellen und Rückenmark vorstellen.
Es gibt, ob es eine Vorwürfe oder Bandscheinevorfall gibt.
Existiert oder vorhanden ist?
Vorhanden ist.
Okay.
Also letztendlich eine besondere Weichteiltechnik sozusagen.
Man kann Weichteil auf Weichteilgewiebete besser darstellen als Röntgen.
Okay.
Wenn jemand z.B. nicht dieser Patient, der ist jung, hat keine Erfolgerung.
Aber wenn jemand kommt mit einem Herdschrittmacher,
was würden Sie da als eine alternative vorschlagen?
CT.
Ja, CT.
Genau.
Richtig.
Da kann man auch Bandscheinvorfall oder Vorwürbungen darstellen.
Aber in einer nicht besseren Qualität, sondern in einer schlechten Qualität.
Ja.
Aber man kann es. Okay, gut.
Eine kardiologeische Konzult ist erforderlich.
Warum?
Weil seit senioren ungefähr alle Schildmacher mit MRT...
Ja.
Nein, nicht kein Problem.
Seit zehn Jahren meinen Sie, dass alle Schildmacher tauglich sind.
Ich würde sagen, dass alle, das viele, würde ich sagen, vorsichtig.
Oder einige.
Einigen.
Ich würde nicht meine Garantie geben, dass alle Schildmacher tauglich sind.
Da brauche ich auch kein kardiologes Konzult.
Ja.
Wie seit wann haben Sie die Schildmacher?
Wenn er sagt, seit zwei Jahren würden Sie direkt den MRT schicken.
Nein.
Ja, deswegen nicht alle.
Erst mal eine kardiologeische Konzult
in dieser Schildmacher stoppieren.
Also, wenn es nötig wäre, meinen Sie, man kann es auch eventuell den Schildmacher pausieren.
Ja.
Okay.
Dann, wie geht es denn weiter?
Sie haben die Diagnostik gemacht und haben festgestellt,
dass dieser Mensch einen Bandscheibenvorfall hat.
Was würden Sie vorschlagen?
Wir würden, wir würden, Krankengymnastik empfehlen.
Und natürlich, wir würden eine energetische Verabreichung
und vielleicht ein muskulärer Relektation verabreichen.
Und was noch?
Krankengymnastik.
Besonders, besonders, wie würden wir NSR empfehlen,
weil NSR die Entzündung dort haben.
Okay.
Der Punkt von wo, was ist entzündet?
Weil die Bandschreibung vorfallt.
Auf den Nervenwurzel.
Ja, Nervenwurzel.
Drückt.
Deswegen, dass ein Entzündlicher Prozess.
Das heißt, deswegen ein Entzündlicher Prozess. Richtig.
Aber wenn jemand eine Paräse hat.
Ja, Paräse.
Laut der Wirbelsäulen-Chirurgen, laut Leitlinie,
der Wirbelsäulen-Chirurgen, wird bei Paräse eine Operation empfohlen.
Ja.
Also bei keiner Paräse, nur ein Bandschreibvorfall mit starken Schmerzen
oder einer Taubheitsgefühl, also eine Paräse,
nicht Paräse, sondern mit einer Parästhesie,
würde man das machen, wie Sie es gesagt haben.
Wenn es nicht hilft, kann man an einer Operation diskutieren,
mit einer Operation denken.
Aber wenn es eine Paräse vorhanden ist, empfiehlt man in der Regel eine Operation.
In Klammern, es sei denn, der Kraftgradverlust ist gering.
Die Kraftgrad unterteilt man in 5.5.
Wenn er ein 4.5. Kraftverlust hat, muss man den Patienten aufklären,
dass man auch konservativ mit Cortison-Injektionen
an den Spinalkanal mit Physiotherapien versuchen kann,
aber keine Garantie gibt.
Ja, okay.
Wenn der Patient aufgeklärt ist, kann man auch konservativ machen,
sonst empfiehlt man eigentlich bei einer Paräse
mehr als 4.5. auf jeden Fall eine Operation.
Okay?
Bis zur Operation kann man den Patienten auch eine Peroneus-Schiene verorten.
Sonst fällt der Fuß immer nach unten,
weil er den nicht hochheben kann beim Laufen.
Eine Ortese, eine Schiene.
Ja, ja, okay.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Gerne.
Habt ihr noch Fragen oder in der Gruppe?